una de las noticias de las estimaciones
y del conteo de los votos es que el de
extrema izquierda jean-luc mélenchon
acortó la distancia con marine lepén
ahora con el 22% de melanio y el 23% de
ma jin le pen en la siesta a menos de un
1% en su discurso malayo evitó decir
directamente que voten por ma chrome
significa que significa esto
bueno primero quisiera aclarar que al
menos unos de ultraizquierda representa
una alternativa de izquierda muy
parecida a lo que fue la
socialdemocracia francesa en los últimos
30 años entonces hay que tener cuidado
con el equiparar a menos a la
ultraizquierda que si existe dentro del
panorama de estas elecciones estamos
hablando también de una diferencia entre
reunir menos o en este momento imagen el
papel del menos de menos del 1 por
ciento 0,8 según el último estimado
entonces pues hay que tener también
cuidado con las predicciones parece que
las cosas ya están digamos claras y que
la segunda vuelta ya está determinada
pero bueno tenemos que seguir un poco
viendo cómo evolucionan los resultados
oficiales él no quiere llamar a votar
por mccann porque particularmente el
electorado de jobbik - está muy bravo
con emanuel macro hacia un presidente
que ha favorecido ciertas categorías de
la población durante su mandato y que ha
sido incluso insultante con las otras
categorías de la población entonces los
tanto si las votantes de yo mismo no son
tienen resentimiento hacia emanuel bach
o no quieren escuchar a su líder llamar
directamente a votar por él pero pues
aclaró que no ni un solo voto de los
suyos puede ir a más y no pena así que
es de manera indirecta un llamado a
votar en contra de la bnp y usted habla
un poco de la violencia que tienen los
franceses y que explica en cierta medida
la abstención que es otra de las
noticias de la jornada pues alrededor
del 26% de las personas que estaban
llamadas a votar prefirieron no hacerlo
como habla esto del hartazgo con la
política tradicional
hay claramente un hartazgo con la
la abstención ha venido subiendo en las
diferentes direcciones francesas en las
últimas décadas pero generalmente
históricamente la elección presidencial
sí ha sido un encuentro entre una
persona un candidato una candidata y la
población entonces siempre ha habido
mucha votación en la elección
presidencial este caso este año es un
poco diferente y no había mucha ilusión
durante la compaña no había mucha mucho
debate tampoco pues ya hemos hablado en
esta en este canal de de que el
presidente macro no quiso participar en
debates en la campaña entonces no hubo
realmente una campaña verdadera con
debates e intercambios de ideas así que
no era una elección muy llamativa para
la población en general y otro de los
puntos importantes que se destacan en
las elecciones presidenciales de francia
es que los partidos republicanos y
socialistas
tuvieron unas derrotas históricas
como entender entonces que dos de los
partidos más tradicionales y más
longevos en francia estén derrotados
frente a otros nuevos como reconquista
de vigo
si podemos ver que realmente esos dos
partidos que han dominado bajo
diferentes nombres han dominado la
política francesa en la segunda en la
pues desde el siglo la segunda mitad del
siglo 20 y principios del siglo 21 y en
este momento están derrotados hay que
repensar la los clivajes las diferencias
que existen a nivel político claramente
en manuel marco no representa cierto
tipo de política de programa político un
programa de de centroderecha con él pues
se una una vocación europea una vocación
al libre mercado a la economía etcétera
y está surgiendo como unos unas
oposiciones una de ultraderecha que
insiste en la parte cultural e
identitaria a la política y una de
izquierda que llama a una
reconfiguración incluso de las
relaciones políticas y en el caso de
henrik menos a una sexta república o sea
una nueva constitución una nueva forma
de hacer política en francia porque él
según él la política de la quinta
república
en francia llegó a su final ya en lo que
podía dar en términos de duración